erster Verein dann die Partei aber im
Grunde dreht sich dann doch alles um
Sarah Wagenknecht und damit einen
schönen guten Abend nach Berlin guten
Abend Frau Wagenknecht die Linke und sie
sie gehen jetzt also auch offiziell
getrennte Wege warum geben sie nicht
auch ihre Mandate ab das wäre doch
konsequent also ich denke das wofür ich
stehe das haben ja viele Menschen auch
gewählt als sie die Linke gewählt haben
und ich erinnere mich als im im Juni der
Parteivorstand mich aufgefordert hat
mein Mandat zu zurückzugeben das wurde
ja damals schon beschlossen haben mir
ganz viele Menschen geschrieben wwag
nicht wenn sie ihr Mandat zurückgeben
dann möchte ich auch meine Stimme zurück
weil ich habe die Linke nicht zuletzt
wegen ihnen gewählt inoweit es ist
natürlich immer ein bitterer Prozess
wenn es zu einem Punkt kommt an dem wir
jetzt stehen aber ich finde wir sollten
jetzt diese Trennung auch mit Anstand
machen und ja uns da nicht mit Reck
bewerfen also ich bin jetzt wirklich
ganz motiviert auf das neue Projekt mich
zu orientieren und das andere ist
Vergangenheit also ein Prozess der ja
auch etwas länger gedauert hat jetzt
haben sie heute wirklich die
Entscheidung getroffen Wähler könnte man
sagen entscheiden natürlich auch und
zwar bei der nächsten Wahl aber das auch
das ist ja ihre Entscheidung ob sie die
Mandate behalten oder nicht der Linken
Chef nennt ihr Vorgehen allerdings
völlig unverantwortlich weil sie das
Nachrücken anderer eben verhindern und
somit die Fraktion zerlegen ist ihn die
Linke mittlerweile so egal nein die
Linke ist mir nicht egal aber wir müssen
einfach sehen die Linke ist leider eine
Partei geworden die politisch von den
Wählern immer mehr abgestraft wurde also
sie war ja mal eine Kraft die auch in
unserem Land etwas bewegt hat Ich habe
mich über viele Jahre in der Linken
engagiert aber durch die Veränderung sie
ist nicht mehr die Partei die sie damals
war die Parteiführung hat ein anderes
Konzept und für dieses Konzept gibt es
ganz offenkundig nur noch ein sehr sehr
kleines Wählerpotenzial und das ist der
Hauptgrund warum Menschen in der Linken
begonnen haben auch schon vor mir und
unabhängig von mir darüber nachzudenken
denken ob es nicht eine neue Kraft
braucht und es geht ja gar nicht primär
um die Linke sondern ich finde wir haben
in Deutschland einfach ein ganz große
repräsentationslücke viele Menschen
wissen nicht mehr was sie wählen sollen
wir leben in einer Zeit massiver
geopolitischer weltpolitischer Krisen
und wir haben gleichzeitig die
schlechteste Regierung die die
Bundesrepublik jemals hatte und es muss
sich einfach etwas verändern sonst sehe
ich wirklich sehr schwarz für die
Zukunft weil wir haben die Gefahr dass
Deutschland wirtschaftlich absteigt und
das möchte ich gerne ver es sind
natürlich komplexe Herausforderungen
viele Kriege und Krisen darauf antworten
einfache vor allen Dingen zu finden das
ist eben unmöglich thürings AFD Chef
höcke der hatte ihn ja Anfang des Jahres
angeboten bei der AFD mitzumachen sicher
auch weil damals wie heute viele AFD
Wähler Sie eventuell wählen würden
aktuell wo laut einer Umfrage zwischen
und0% trifft das ihr politisches
Spektrum also kämpfen sie um das gleiche
kentel also ich denke es täte den
Debatten in Deutschland gut wenn wir
mehr über vernünftige Politik und
weniger über die AFD diskutieren würden
und natürlich gibt es ganz viele
Menschen die wählen die AFD nicht weil
sie recht sind sondern weil sie wütend
sind weil sie verzweifelt sind weil sie
das ist ja auch ein Grund warum wir an
den Staat gegangen sind mir haben ganz
viele gesagt wir wissen nicht mehr was
wir wählen sollen in den vorhandenen
Parteien ist für uns nichts wir sind äh
zutiefst äh wütend darüber wie schlecht
dieses Land regiert wird wie falsch die
Prioritäten sind die die Ampel setzt sie
die Menschen haben das Gefühl es muss
sich was ändern und viele haben daraus
den Schluss gezogen okay wenn jetzt
erstmal nichts anderes da ist wählen wir
AFD wir wollen diesen Menschen ein
seriöses Angebot geben wir woll aber
Frau WAG nichtcht wenn ich sie da ganz
kurz unterbrechen darf es ist ja so dass
Menschen sie jetzt eventuell wählen
würden obwohl sie weder Programm noch
Personal kennen also heißt das nicht es
geht gar nicht mehr so sehr um Inhalte
und
Überzeugung ja wir haben ja heute mit
dem stat des Vereins auch ein Programm
vorgelegt natürlich ist das noch nicht
30 Seiten lang sondern das sind vier
wesentliche Punkte aber diese vier
Punkte dafür stehen wir das ist einmal
eine Politik eine Wirtschaftspolitik
eine Energiepolitik die vernünftig ist
die die industrielle Wertschöpfung hier
in Deutschland erhält die einen starken
Mittelstand erhält der zweite große
Punkt soziale Gerechtigkeit meine
Deutschland ist in den letzten Jahren
immer weiter auseinandergedriftet die
hat von den fleißigen zu den oberen 10
000 umverteilt wir brauchen gute Löhne
ein ordentliches Rentensystem das ist in
manchen westeuropäischen Ländern
deutlich besser geregelt und unsere
drittes großes anlegen wir brauchen eine
Außenpolitik die sich wieder an den
Traditionen der Entspannungspolitik
orientiert also auf Diplomatie setzt
Deutschland hat lange Zeit ist sehr gut
damit gefahren auf Vermittlung auf
Ausgleich zetzen und nicht auf
militärische Lösungen und vielepolitik
sie haben das friedliche Außenpolitik
genannt
sie haben sich ja heute bei der
Pressekonferenz dann auch zum Krieg in
Israel geäußert da haben sie gesagt der
Staat hätte selbstverständlich das Recht
sich gegen die Angriffe der terrormiliz
Hamas zu verteidigen zudem sagten sie
aber auch dass Gaza seit vielen Jahren
ein freiluftgefängnis sei machen Sie
denn dafür nur wenn man bei ihrem
wording auch bleibt nur Israel oder
vielleicht auch Ägypten und vor allen
Dingen die Terrorgruppe Hamas
verantwortlich ja natürlich gibt es
viele Verantwortliche meine Botschaft
war ja nur auch dieser Konflikt wird
sich nicht mit Waffen und mit
militärischen Mitteln lösen lassen und
ich sehe mit großer Sorge eine
bevorstehende Bodenoffensive weil ich
denke dass das ganz ganz viele
Zivilisten das Leben kosten wird und es
kann den ganzen Nahen Osten zu einem
Pulverfass machen also auch dieser
Konflikt muss diplomatisch gelöst werden
und der wird auch nicht gelöst werden
können ohne dass die Interessen auch der
Palästinenser berücksichtigt werden ja
sie sprachen dann auch von einer
zweiaatenlösung die ja viele befürworten
auch deutsche Politiker z.B auch der
Bundespräsident und andere aber wie soll
das jetzt gehen verhandeln mit der
Terrorgruppe Hamas oder mit wem nein
also mit der Hamas muss man nicht
verhandeln die es gibt ja durchaus
andere Repräsentanten der Palästinenser
ich glaube nur dass es wirklich wichtig
wäre dass die israelische Regierung die
ja aktuell die zwei staatenlösung
ablehnt hier andere Signale setzt damit
es einen Frieden gibt damit es eine
friedliche Lösung gibt weil die
Vorstellung dass dieser Konflikt einfach
bleibt und man das wegmoderiert das kann
nicht funktionieren und natürlich haben
die Palästinenser auch ein Recht auf
ihre Interessen und dass die Situation
in Gaza so nicht bleiben kann das ist ja
tatsächlich der Fall ja sagt Sarah
Wagenknecht insbesondere sind heute
glaube ich erstmal auch viele gespannt
wie es mit ihrem Bündnis weitergeht sie
streben jedenfalls anbeit allen drei
Landtagswahlen im nächsten Jahr im
Ostenland dabei zu sein inklusive
Thüringen wo die Linke den
Ministerpräsidenten stellt Frau
Wagenknecht vielen Dank für Ihre Zeit
sehr gerne